While looking at options for breast cancer treatment, it's become apparent that a mastectomy
This is for this person
Of my left breast would require a skin transfer from my stomach to close the wound
So sometimes people don't have enough
flesh the breast might be really small
And they need to do a skin graft to close the wound would a skin transfer trigger unwanted
cell growth like elective surgeries we talked about last week
Well any surgery is going to stimulate your body to need to heal from that wound
So you just have to do what you have to do
So I think having the blood surgery they'll do the skin graft immediately to close that wound
Yeah, I wouldn't hesitate to do that
You need not that what it has to take to do that